finally sunshine has multiple activities
and we can move between them using
intents we also know how to use implicit
intents to integrate activities from
other apps in this lesson we'll dive
into just how the android framework
deals with your activities in particular
how the activity lifecycle may be
different from what you used to from
other platforms and environments don't
worry there's plenty of code for you to
write yes plenty of code lots and lots
and lots of code will move sunshine
along implementing an underlying
database and wrapping that in a content
provider everything you need to know to
use persistent storage the goal is to
ensure your app provides a seamless
efficient experience for your users
even when networks may be slow or
unavailable